where they hate women if anything they
love women for a man to tell you to
think positively how is that hatred the
people are literally telling us that
what we think is what's going to
manifest so therefore think positive
thoughts and positive things will happen
to you you guys on this table who are
talking about families you're all
negative because why would you focus so
much on comments why would you focus so
much on who's looking at your hairstyle
your accent or whatever and then someone
comes to tell you actually focus on the
positive and you guys are saying they
hate you no you can't focus on them just
the other day a man applied for a job
and they told him he can't get the job
because of his afraid so you can't tell
us to not focus on it when it is the
focus
and watch the news it literally happened
the other day yeah but that's his
experience but if he was smart he's not
gonna let that hold him back oh that's
the whole point on the news
you can't tell us to not focus on it a
certain place in my afraid the first
thing people are going to do is stare at
me and certain places wouldn't want to
give me the job just because you want me
to tell you something but that's your
mindset you should change it you can't